[Music]
okay so
here's another thing i want to i want to
get into this test your girl tik tok and
this will be maybe
a little bit of a relationship advice
segment we haven't done one of those in
a little bit yeah like not on the new
ship at least yeah
and so this actually will be a good um
it's like a new form of that honestly
there's this kid on tick tock
he's like what you know kind of a chad
he's a chad looking guy
his name's sean sean and what he does
is guys yo that name is more [ __ ] up
than your name
yeah what's his last name go up that has
to be tied to manskalski
that's how you pronounce that i think
that's that's the proper polish way
this is sean co he's got co in his name
yeah exactly
no the first two we look alike too we
both have sick jaw lines
yeah we do what do you mean me and him
we're like
bros yeah you and sean sis yeah is that
s z
yeah sean sizza s z y
sean seesy that's what it is says
mikowski sisminkowski
yeah sis makowski so he has what sounds
like
he has guys guys will tell their no
he'll
tell them to dm guys will tell this kid
to dm their girls to see if they're
faithful
yeah and what they do and then this guy
posts it all on tick tock
unbelievable this is exposing at a new
level
genius sean genius it really is genius
and it's
very heartbreaking and also really
entertaining so
what's the one that i sent you
oh [ __ ] i'm going to tell him to do this
to alina then i'm just going to have
elena reply to him and be like
wacky just in audio notes yeah
yeah and it's just you yeah bro you
gotta hit my girl man i've just been
like really nervous so
she keeps you know being weird about her
phone and all this [ __ ]
and he's like cool man i got you hey
babe whoa
kenny
he's like damn girl is is that you
farting
[Laughter]
what was that one the [ __ ] laughing i
was like oh no no
no no
okay
i said hey broski i need your help my
wife's 34 and i think she's in the
younger eyes like 19
22. what the [ __ ]
hey what's up guys hey what's up guys
raider tech here we're reviewing the new
iphone 57. my wife is into young
guys like 19 18 17.
that's almost 17. because that's a legal
monotone
this person's relationship is ruined
it's his wife like
this is this goes so much deeper than he
could ever comprehend he's like yo
what's up guys welcome back to
uh relationship breaker uh today we got
this guy
he's really [ __ ] uh he's his wife's
into younger guys
i'm kind of perfect for that because i'm
18 and i'm [ __ ] cool jaw so
anybody's going to just damn her and say
what's up hey you want to suck my [ __ ]
she said yes you guys so i'm going to
follow up and say can i eat your [ __ ]
so i like for part two when she sucks my
cup yeah all right guys i'm heading to
her place right now
at the end of the tick tock this is her
this is this is what you look like when
you're giving head
[Laughter]
this is what you look like when you're
giving head this is what your wife looks
like
when she's talking what's up you guys
currently getting ahead from this guy's
wife it's pretty good six out of ten i
would say
all right leah let it let it go you have
a four-year-old
and me a lot i was like but i got you
i'll let you know so i started saying
hey
started slow she said hello i said how
are you she said fine how are you and i
said no now i'm talking to you pretty
good
gotta be smooth with it always so that
was sweet always very young
not saying it's a bad thing and then i
said i'm 20.
you look like 25 right and i said 34.
and that gorgeous damn and she said
you're actually so sweet i got to feel
the process so i said
um i just honestly just really
attractive and maybe we could see each
other
all right she then says you just met me
but i went on to pass up on that
opportunity
so i sent a winky face because like you
know then i want to ask questions so i
said have you ever got with any guys my
age before
she said you will be my first she said
will like it's going to happen so
i said it so you're saying it's gonna
happen send me a picture i'm not gonna
say what she sent me
um but you guys can obviously know it
was her biggest idea
[Laughter]
yeah it was like her 34 year old big old
milkhorse
so then she sent me a picture of her big
old milky jugs um can't wait to suck on
those
sick nipples oh yeah gotta be smooth
with it so i went over there
and uh send her a picture of my penis
and
uh yeah like for part two when i
suckered big juicy milkers
imagine being the dude watching this
just listening to this voice yep so uh
damn
they have a porter all together
what did he send you [ __ ]
[ __ ] pink juicy milkers did he suck
your big juicy milk or tell me the
[ __ ] truth
where did you send him what did you send
him did you send him a picture of your
[ __ ]
and then were you fingering it
didn't you oh you got a squirrel over
your pretty feet
just ugly crying snot out of his nose
was it bigger was it big don't lie to me
on the phone was it was it younger
what what was it he was a gooder
calling this boy
and then c c c
[Music]
[Laughter]
no cry like the silent like and then cry
when do you finish
okay jesus he finished his finished all
over my big 34 year old big juicy milk
let's go back to regular life bro people
on
the last on the bonus episode when we
did that [ __ ] some dude was like i was
laughing until halfway through and then
you guys hit way too close to home
exactly that was everyone's comments
it got way too real we've all been there
how can you not laugh
we've all been there now you know
you know what happens after this you
know what he has to perfect what
so do what happened with my wife oh
she's a nice girl yeah yeah exactly
yeah i took care of it i took care of
her
what what do you mean she's good man
she's a nice girl she's not a girl
she's a [ __ ] woman she's a woman
she's giving birth you [ __ ]
she's a mother of my child
did you [ __ ] [ __ ] juice
then you suck the tinnies then she
sucked my dick and then i sucked in her
left titty
gotta be smooth with it gotta be smooth
with it i licked her right nipple
like the rust nipple we did doggy and
then i think she got on top we did
reverse cowgirl for a second
god damn bro that's a brutal way to go
out yeah that
sucks test my girl jesus
i mean i can't figure out if this guy's
like doing a service or if this is just
kind of messed up i think it's
i think it's a service yeah yeah he's
getting the ugly truth out there yeah
hey now you got a four-year-old but the
ugly truth is
your wife wants to [ __ ] 19-year-old
guy yeah or he's 20 right
he's 20 yeah yeah let's [ __ ] 20 year old
guy she wants [ __ ] cody
sean sis yeah my bro yeah
you